so it is no secret that this was a year
of great shooters to say the least and
to make the top of our list you had to
really pull your weight and titanfall 2
has done that in almost every aspect
standby for titanfall
tight ball one was a great game but it
kind of dropped off after a while it
kind of felt like there was something
missing titanfall 2 has remedied almost
all of that become one of our favorite
games the year that a lot of us in the
office cannot stop playing can I stop
talking about Rob as a sequel widest
titanfall to make the best of the first
game and kind of just feel like the game
respawn Entertainment's should have made
a couple years ago having been such a
huge fan of the first game there's no
lie that so many of us just stopped
playing and I would say a lot of that
was the progression system among many
things the progression system here is at
its best where you're playing for longer
with double the amount of things you can
do in all forms of the multiplayer you
have things like mobility which I
cherish you know the idea of wall
running and being able to cheat death is
much stronger here instead of having a
very frantic wall running situation they
toned it down here and they said hey
chain your wall runs and gain speed
in which case you're making things more
predictable and and you're just
basically rewarding a player and that
respect get good ad wall running and you
can find a way to cheat that sniper
across the entire map
so this all around it's just rewarding
you for things that the first game
didn't necessarily do there's much more
measured pace this time around Aaron as
someone who plays a lot like Rainbow six
siege and you played overwatch and I
know you dabble in battle born hero
shooters have kind of been slowly taking
over the genre and titanfall to actually
shows a lot of that with its new Titans
there's these six distinct hero class is
almost in these new Titans can you talk
about how that changes up the
multiplayer formula I think one of the
most important things about titanfall is
the intentional design of these hero
classes and how they play with each
other about how you as a player will
round a corner and see another Titan
that you can recognize and know whether
you have the ability to take them on or
not
I mean the other thing is that this is a
game where Titans make players feel
momentarily powerful and that's a tough
thing to do in a shooter without making
other people feel like it's unfair so in
this game you're temporarily powerful
with individual loadouts of titans and
those titans all do you know play within
the rules beautifully and it's about
knowing which Titan drop when such as
you'll find in a hero shooter but also
knowing when to get out of your tight
and just be a good running gun player
and the dynamic of all that is what
makes titanfall to you so incredible
yes the Titans make this game worth
learning worth experimenting with and
that's the multiplayer we haven't even
talked about the single-player campaign
yet and it's excellent
and what we wanted out of that single
player campaign was a better way of
delivering what this universe all about
through narrative it did that I would
say it definitely was able to achieve
that but where everyone was surprised
was how each level had its own
brilliance and replayability factor
taking a mechanic that you thought was
pretty one noted and completely blow
your mind the effect and cause mission
is just one of the most memorable
missions of the year yeah and speaking
of neo tiden classes the single player
definitely was able to teach you how to
play each Titan with the ability to
change through each one of them on the
fly so you know it was a great learning
ground in discovering who did you fit in
the thing i love about sign fall is
everyone is so well diverse and can find
their play style and have that argument
on why it is so successful
yeah when all is said and done it
released between the stellar
single-player campaign and this nuance
multiplayer you know the one thing we
were worried about is can tighten fault
to survive past those couple of weeks
right but now there's this progression
tree which you know in my opinion and
the opinion of a lot of people here just
as this vitality the game Marin key tell
me about that like sense of discovery
you get from this progression tree yeah
titan falls progression tree just
rekindle my love of trying to figure out
what things do there's a lot of shooters
these days where you pick up a gun and
you know what a gun does or you pick up
a grenade you know what a grenade does
but in titanfall you start with a
problem a lot of times i need to grunt
form better so what do I have what can I
try I've got gravity star so you start
using gravity starter group grows
together and blow them up and something
you got Titans down faster and then
you're discovering Titans how does this
time to work how can i play with this
tighten in this strategy and as that
happens you can realize like maybe my
Titan isn't powerful enough let me go
through the boost tree okay there's a
battery so now I've got this killer
Titan loadout I didn't have you know two
days ago and that all just came from hey
like what does gravity star do and then
you get you watch some YouTube videos it
turns out gravity star actually bends
Titan rockets next you know Rob and I
are coming in every day having one of
those conversations did you know this
can do that and to me those are the best
shooters are the ones where you pick
something up you don't know what it does
you you master it and then somebody
teaches you something
yeah again in a year of fantastic
shooters you have to do a lot to set
yourself apart from the pack but
titanfall 2 did just that I think it's
the mark of a good game and even better
shooter that you can just learn more and
discover more the more you play and I'm
going to be playing titanfall 2 for much
longer and I'm sure a lot of people here
will be and that's why it made the
number 3 game of the year here at
gamespot
you
[Music]